do you remember when we're having a look
at this table here which helped us
understand if you know what the
derivative is doing then you can know
what the graph is doing and you've been
spending some time say oh it's
increasing it's decreasing sometimes
you're specifically looking for a
particular place or domain where it's
increasing decreasing or stationary and
I left this gap right I said hey
sometimes it's weird but sometimes the
derivative is neither positive nor
negative nausea
sometimes it just is no derivative the
example I gave you was if the function
doesn't exist y equals one over X is a
good example okay we know it's got a
vertical asymptote if the function
doesn't exist what its derivative won't
exist either because it doesn't make
sense to say hey what is the gradient of
my non-existent graph right graph
doesn't exist trivia doesn't exist
either but then I left this open
question I said that's not the only
circumstance under which this can happen
and help you understand why I want you
to follow through this example with me
you'll need some space to work out and
do this with me okay now why cos cube
root of x is a very important function
basically so I can illustrate this
particular case of what's going on if we
wanted to understand what this thing is
doing on the basis of calculus well it
is to differentiate it any problem is in
its current form it's not written in a
nice way to differentiate right in in
much the same way that this is not
written in that way
it's a differentiate what would we do to
rewrite this to make differentiation
more straightforward x2 that to the
power of negative 1 and you're like oh
I'm in index form now and I just use my
normal rules and off I go okay we can do
much the same with this you've just got
to think back to your index laws how
would I rewrite this max X to the power
of 1/3 very good okay
and hopefully you were like yes I know
my index laws now we can differentiate
this and I'm lucky to do this with me
okay if this is my function then dy on
DX equals okay let's have a think it's a
very simple expression I'm just going to
bring that index out the front which
means 1 over 3 and then you what's the
second step you subtract one from the
index now 1/3 take away one
is negative 2/3 negative 2/3 now at this
point I could just say I'm done I've
differentiated but to make more obvious
what's going on here
I need this chair here so I'm just going
to be clumsy I'm gonna write it slightly
differently like negative indices we
don't usually like negative indices we
would usually rewrite that as instead of
multiplication this is actually division
so this this X term belongs on the
denominator with this 3 so I'm gonna
write it as 1 over it's already a 3
there yeah you see that and then you've
got the X to the power of 2/3 are you ok
with that
doesn't look a bit weird but but that's
what it is ok and the reason why I'm
writing in this way is so that you can
see just like with this guy right if I
try to put in a particular value of x
this thing blows up what value of x
makes this stop working x equals 0
because now you've got zero in the
denominator again right now it's
tempting to think that if you put x
equals zero in here it's like oh okay
I'm not allowed to do that I'm not
allowed to divide by zero there's
tempting to think oh it must be one of
these things right but it's not because
have a look back at this original
function go back try this out when x
equals zero what does y equal what is
the cube root of 0 its 0 right it's the
number you multiply by itself three
times to get this right well 0 does
exist man like it's kind of important
yeah so so hold on a second get this
with me right there there is no
discontinuity this function exists it's
domain is all values of X so it's fine
okay but it's derivative doesn't exist
so this point what I want you to do I
can do this quicker because I'm familiar
with it but you might want to grab out
desmos so you can bring your laptop back
to life what does this thing look like
well I'm going to show you what the
function looks like you can access the
cube root of x by the way on that
keyboard down buddy just going to kind
of go find it
this is what the function looks like are
you getting something like that you see
it there
I got my ankles Cooper Dex yes it's in
the miscellaneous functions because I
think square root of is is just there
but to get different routes like this
I'm is a cube root here right you're
gonna have to go into that bottom
right-hand side yes you can't do that to
thank you parents it's a just a minor
flex there I appreciate that I know my
dismal shortcuts man okay okay so I hope
you're there now there's a few things I
want to point out about this right
number one this is a function with some
symmetry I'm just pulling this out from
last topic function symmetry whereby I
could take this guy and I could rotate
it 180 degrees about the origin and
you'd get back the same function one we
call that by the way kind of symmetry is
that I think again I'm rotating around
right this rotational symmetry which in
the context of functions we would call
this an odd function okay by the way
it's the cube root of x + 3 is an odd
number not a coincidence okay I'll leave
that to one side
it's an odd function but also please
notice it's continuous is you can put
any value of x in here that you like I'm
unlike square roots you can put negative
numbers in here and everything is handy
data it's fine okay so it works it's not
a discontinuity but at this spot right
here the derivative doesn't exist and my
question to you is why not what we just
went and tried right and your derivative
just explodes why shouldn't there be a
derivative there look graph looks pretty
normal right what are you thinking Zack
you think our lab with me
point but on the vertical axis so it's
never really flat as far as I'm aware we
haven't found any way of describing hmm
yeah very good Suzanne keys sir on the
right track here right this feels like
in terms of come back and look at your
table right come back and with your
table if you were trying to compare this
to something it feels like it's closest
to this right except that it's not
because this is horizontal you know this
is like going up this has gone down this
is horizontal we don't have anywhere on
our page where you've got something
that's up-and-down do you notice that we
don't have any vertical lines so in fact
what you've got here are the tangent to
this graph you've actually already drawn
the tangent it's the y-axis right now
why does that cause problems for the
derivative look at even the way we write
the derivative right dy/dx it's kind of
our algebraic shorthand for rise over
run yeah but this point at this point
here right this this infinite right is
and there's no room right do you see
that it's like it's equal to zero so
that's why even though the function
exists the derivative doesn't so coming
back to our table we can complete it now
okay if you have or you try and find the
derivative and doesn't exist either
you've got discontinuity or your graph
is vertical and our example for this is
y equals the cube root of x there are of
course others that do this but this is
just the simplest example that I can
draw okay have a look at your derivative
based on what it's equal to you can know
what it's doing but this is a weird case
this is where like your rules start to
break down a little bit so you have to
be more careful basically well dy/dx
isn't vertical the original graph is
vertical so that's why I've put it over
here in this column